Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg is
apologizing for his company's role in
that data mining scandal Zuckerberg
spoke for the first time yesterday about
how Facebook mishandled the date of more
than 50 million users that data was
collected by an app and later sold to
Cambridge analytic a consultant to
Donald Trump's presidential campaign
anyone whose data might have been
affected by this we're gonna we're gonna
make sure that we tell and going forward
when we when we identify apps that that
are similarly doing sketchy things we're
gonna make sure that we tell people then
to Mark Zuckerberg also revealed in that
CNN interview he is willing to testify
before Congress and he said he's open to
more regulations on tech companies
vladimir duthiers our streaming network
cbsn is following this unfolding story
Vlad good morning good morning this data
scandal has plagued the social media
giant for days Facebook stock is down
and the company is facing mounting
pressure from lawmakers for transparency
yesterday Zuckerberg finally addressed
concerns and began answering questions
this was a major breach of trust and and
I'm really sorry that this happened in a
rare television interview Facebook CEO
Mark Zuckerberg acknowledged his company
should have done more to protect its
users data we can't do that then we
don't deserve to have the opportunity to
serve people in 2013 a researcher built
a personality quiz app that collected
psychological data from Facebook users
and some of their friends the
information was then sold to a third
party
Cambridge analytic and used in targeted
political advertising if you can't share
data in a way that that people don't
don't know we're don't consent to
Zuckerberg said Wednesday that in 2015
journalist told Facebook that Cambridge
analytic had data from its users
Facebook asked the company to delete the
data Zuckerberg said Facebook believe
Cambridge analytic ahead after it
provided them with a formal
certification I'm used to when people
legally certify that they're gonna do
something that they do it in a Facebook
post earlier Wednesday Zuckerberg
outlines some of the changes the company
vows to
he said Facebook will investigate all
apps that had access to large amounts of
information prior to 2014
when they reduced data access Facebook
will ban any developer that does not
agree to a thorough audit and take steps
to help users understand which apps
they've allowed to access their data
we're going to review thousands of apps
this is gonna be an intensive process
but this is important
Cambridge analytic assess it will
undergo an independent investigation
Facebook CEO Sheryl Sandberg also broke
her silence yesterday calling the
scandal a major violation of people's
trust zuckerberg also revealed he
doesn't know if there are other groups
like Cambridge analytic in possession of
Facebook user data
thank you very much lad